[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
während die Ukraine auf den
Schlachtfeldern vorrückt kämpfen die
Europäer weiter an der gasfront dabei an
einem Strang zu ziehen erweist sich aber
mal wieder als schwierig das werden noch
interessante Diskussionen beim EU-Gipfel
diese Woche
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
kündigte heute ein Konzept für einen
gemeinsamen europäischen gaspreisdeckel
an zugleich warten wir hier in
Deutschland hier alle noch gespannt auf
die Ausgestaltung der deutschen Gaspreis
Bremse derweil die Ampelkoalition eine
gemeinsame Dienstreise nach Spanien
unternommen hat ein in vieler Hinsicht
angenehmes Reiseziel die
deutsch-spanischen Beziehungen sind
hervorragend und nebenbei hat Spanien na
was wohl Gas Terminals Andreas kühners
berichtet
als Olaf Scholz an diesem Mittag einmal
wieder seine reisejacke anzieht und
seine Reise Tasche nimmt um einmal
wieder über Erdgas zu reden war er
bereits in Saudi-Arabien um über Erdgas
zu reden in Katar den Emiraten in
Norwegen und Senegal der
Wirtschaftsminister war um über Erdgas
zu reden in den Emiraten
Qatar und Norwegen die Außenministerin
war überall und heute kommen auch noch
die Minister für Arbeit für Bildung für
Finanzen für Verteidigung und
Landwirtschaft mit nach Spanien
dass sich in La Coruna an der
Atlantikküste die deutsche Regierung mit
der spanischen trift war lange
vereinbart
das ein paar Leute Olaf Olaf rufen war
vielleicht ein klein bisschen erhofft
aber dass die Deutschen nun auch mit den
Spaniern über erdgasreden war nicht
abzusehen jetzt ist es dringend
Ministerpräsident Sanchez hat Gas
Kanzler Scholz braucht Gas aber beide
haben ein Problem sie bekommen das
spanische Gas nicht nach Deutschland
wir haben uns mit der Notwendigkeit
befasst die Infrastruktur auszubauen und
einen echten europäischen Binnenmarkt zu
schaffen wir sind beide dafür
dank seiner 6 lng-terminals verfügt
Spanien über mehr verflüssigtes Erdgas
als es verbrauchen kann Netzbetreiber
ENA Gas würde gern größere Mengen nach
Mitteleuropa exportieren aber zwischen
Spanien und Deutschland liegt ein
Problem Frankreich zur sogenannten mit
cut-pipeline die Spanien nach Norden
fertig bauen will sagt die französische
Regierung seit Jahren noch
Präsident macron war vorgestern im
Kanzleramt und bisher unerbittlich
frankreich will selbst Strom und Gas
nach Deutschland exportieren
mittelfristig und lieber Olaf die
spanische Pipeline hilft euch doch wenn
überhaupt erst langfristig
im Moment verstehe ich nicht ich sage
das ganz naiv was uns das kurzfristig
bringen soll bei dem Problem dass wir zu
lösen versuchen
genervt fragt macron warum man auf dem
Thema herumspringe wie die Pyrenäen
Ziegen aber in LA corunia heute abend
Scholz und Sanchez springen weiter mit
Kat müsse ja keine reine Erdgasleitung
bleiben
durch midcat könnten die iberische
Halbinseln Mitteleuropa für den
künftigen Transport von Wasserstoff
verbunden werden und ich werde
ausdrücklich dafür dass wir diese
Verbindung schaffen Deutschland redet
Deutschland wirbt mit allen möglichen
Ministern mit allen möglichen Ländern
vielleicht müssen ein paar von ihnen
noch mal nach Frankreich fahren um über
Erdgas zu reden
ob einer solchen neue mediterrane
Pipeline gebaut wird oder nicht eines
hat man jetzt in Europa jedenfalls auch
gelernt in den vielen bitteren
Erkenntnissen der letzten sieben Monate
Pipelines sind nicht sicher auch nicht
wenn sie tief auf dem Meeresboden liegen
in einem Hybriden Krieg wie Russland in
führt können Sie Angriffsziele werden
und das gilt natürlich nicht nur für
Pipelines sondern auch für andere
Leitungen und Netze wie sich die
Europäer dagegen wappnen wollen
berichten Ulf Röller und Julia rech
es sind diese Bilder die die Gefahr
unter Wasser ins Bewusstsein der
Menschen gebrannt haben der Krieg wird
nicht nur in der Luft zu Land sondern
auch in den Tiefen des Meeres geführt
der Angriff hat Europa wachgerüttelt
wenn uns jemand gesagt hätte dass wir
eine Explosion an den nordstream
Pipelines haben hätten wir gesagt ach
komm
aber jetzt ist dies die neue Realität
nur wie schützt sich Europa und der
Westen konsequent und robust soll die
Antwort auf den Angriff sein sagt die EU
und die NATO
aber viele Gefahren lauern unter dem
Meeresspiegel
Kampftaucher können Pipelines und
Versorgungskabel erreichen um
Sprengstoff anzubringen aber auch
unbemannte Unterwasser Drohnen oder ein
von einem U-Boot abgeschossenes Torpedo
der Krieg unter Wasser hinterlässt kaum
Spuren
unter Wasser ist es viel schwieriger den
Angreifer zu identifizieren deshalb sind
diese Angriffe so gefährlich und
effizient
seit Jahren rüsten die Weltmächte am
Meeresboden auf es gibt auch hier das
Duell USA gegen Russland moskau ist
gerade unter Wasser eine macht das Land
besitzt unbemannte Drohnen die viele
Kilometer tief tauchen können
am Meeresboden liegen die Lebensadern
der vernetzten Welt
Versorgungskabel für internetstrom
datenrohstoffe wenn sie zerstört werden
ist unser tägliches Leben bedroht
wenn ein Angreifer wirklich fest
entschlossen ist dann wird er einen
Schwachpunkt finden vor allem wenn ihm
die Konsequenzen egal sind oder wenn es
ihm nur wichtiger ist den Feind härter
zu treffen als sich selbst es gibt keine
absolute Sicherheit
Europas Infrastruktur ist verwundbar und
damit wächst die Angst deshalb haben die
nationalen Regierungen ihre Kontrollen
auf und Untersee verstärkt
auch auf dem EU-Gipfel in Prag wollen
Sie über ein Sicherheitskonzept
nachdenken am Ende wird es auch um mehr
Geld für Waffen gehen aber alles beginnt
mit einer Bestandsaufnahme
die Tests werden zeigen ob die
schutzinstrumente ausreichen und wir
genug Mittel besitzen um solche Vorfälle
zu verhindern
solche Vorfälle eine diplomatische
Umschreibung für die Schlacht in der
Tiefe der Gipfel muss eine Antwort
finden für die Zeitenwende die auch am
Meeresboden angekommen ist
zu den größten Baustellen dieser
zeitenwände gehört für die deutsche
Politik das Land erstmal durch diesen
Winter zu führen ohne dass es zu jenen
gesellschaftlichen Verwerfungen kommt
auf die man in Moskau hofft also für
Energiesicherheit sorgen hohe Preise
abfedern soziale Schutzschirme
aufspannen um all das ging es ja auch
beim bund-ländertreffen gestern im
Kanzleramt das aber noch nicht viel
Konkretes herauskam ist bei solchen
Verhandlungen zwar nicht ganz
überraschend sorgt angesichts der
drängenden Zeit aber für Kritik aus
Berlin Frank Buchwald
so richtig zufrieden sieht keiner aus am
Morgen im Kabinett nicht der Vize nicht
erkanzler und auch Christian Lindner
nicht eine Verständigung mit den Ländern
misslungen dass er sehnte 200 Milliarden
Entlastungspaket weiter in der Schwebe
und die Opposition macht Druck der Bund
muss jetzt sagen wie das alles
finanziert werden soll er hat ja nun
wirklich große Finanzmittel ins
Schaufenster gestellt und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch die Betriebe
in Deutschland haben kein Verständnis
mehr dafür dass der Bund mit den Ländern
streitet dass die Bundesregierung
untereinander streitet der Streit muss
aufhören bis spät am Abend hatten sie
gestern beraten Kanzler und
Ministerpräsidenten ohne Ergebnis jedoch
Olaf Scholz danach bemüht optimistisch
ich habe den Eindruck dass wir davon
sehr konstruktiven Pfad unterwegs sind
und uns auch miteinander über diese
Aufgabe verständigen werden der
Vorsitzende der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hätte sich
ja gerne etwas mehr Beute aus Berlin
mitgebracht Stefan weil will am Sonntag
eine Wahl gewinnen nun wird auch er um
Verständnis
das ist nicht so trivial weil eben eine
energiepreisdeckel zu entwerfen der
wirksam ist und der in der Praxis
funktioniert an dieser Stelle müssen wir
tatsächlich auch sicher sein dass die
Vorschläge dann auch anschließend in der
Praxis sich bewähren so viel
Gelassenheit Strahlen andere nicht aus
gerade ostministerpräsidenten denen die
AFD im Nacken Sitz drücken aufs Tempo
parteiübergreifend dauert alles viel zu
lange wir haben ja als Länder in der
letzten Woche zusammengesessen und
ziemlich klar gesagt was kommen muss
auch weil wir mit den Kommunen weil wir
mit der Wirtschaft gesprochen aber wir
ganz nah an den Bürgern sind und die
Menschen verlieren die Nerven die
Unternehmen wissen nicht mehr wie es
weitergeht es dauert einfach zu lang wir
erwarten auch als
Ministerpräsidenten und zwar alle 16
Ministerpräsidenten dass wir zügiger für
die Bürger klar erkennbar machen können
dass der
primärenergiepreis deutlich nach unten
gedreht wird noch aber war es niemand so
genau wie der geplante gaspreisdeckel
eigentlich funktionieren kann Experten
soll zu klären außerdem wollen wir noch
die neue Steuerschätzung für das nächste
Jahr einen beziehen und auf der
Grundlage kann es danach erst eine
konkrete finanzielle Verabredung
zwischen Bund und Ländern geben das
wissen natürlich auch die
Ministerpräsidenten und manche rüsten
deshalb schon mal ab zumindest
sprachlich es nutzt überhaupt gar nichts
wenn man jetzt Schuldzuweisungen
ausspricht es nutzt auch gar nichts wenn
man mit dem Finger aufeinander zeigt ich
warne vor allem davor von einem
Scheitern der Gespräche zu sprechen viel
Zeit nämlich bleibt ihnen nicht der
Winter kommt und je weiter die
Temperaturen fallen desto mehr nimmt die
Ungeduld zu in Berlin und überall in
Deutschland
mit dem Blick auf das Kriegsgeschehen
geht es jetzt bei dir erstmal weiter
Heinz ja russlands Präsident Putin
treibt die Annexion von vier
ukrainischen Gebieten weiter voran er
unterzeichnete heute die Gesetze dazu
die Gebiete herrson saporicia luhanski
damit laut Russland offiziell unter dem
Schutz der atomwacht die ukrainische
Armee hat nach Angaben von Präsident
selenski weitere Gebietsgewinne in den
Regionen nicht herrson und Johannes
erzielt dutzende Dörfer seien befreit
worden so selensky im Großraum Kiew
wurde durch russische Angriffe mit
Kampfdrohnen wie der Gouverneur sagte
Infrastruktur getroffen
in Kirch wächst auch die Sorge vor
atomarenangriffen die Reserven an
Jodtabletten wurden aufgestockt und
Evakuierungspläne vorbereitet
in Deutschland sollen zum Ausgleich der
hohen Energiepreise die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner bis zum 15 Dezember eine
Einmalzahlung von 300 Euro erhalten
entsprechende Pläne aus dem
Entlastungspaket der Koalition hat das
Kabinett heute beschlossen die
Einmalzahlung erfolgt automatisch durch
die rentenzahlstellen
die britische Premierministerin Trust
hat nach den Turbulenzen um die
Steuerpläne der Regierung ihre Linie
verteidigt zum Abschluss des Parteitags
der konservativen Tories in Birmingham
kündigte sie eine Wirtschafts- und
wachstumsorientierte Politik an die
Pläne zur Senkung der
Spitzensteuersatzes hatte ihre Regierung
nach heftiger auch parteiinterner Kritik
wieder zurückgezogen
US-Präsident beiden ist in Florida
eingetroffen um sich dort ein Bild von
den schweren Schäden durch Hurrikan Ian
zu machen wegen der hohen Zahl an Opfern
stehen die Behörden in der Kritik zu
spät evakuiert zu haben beiden Besuch
zur Stunde die Region um Fort Myers
allein im Florida sind nach offiziellen
Angaben mindestens 85 Menschen getötet
worden weitere Opfer gab es im
Bundesstaat North Carolina der Hurrikan
der zweithöchsten Kategorie 4 hatte
massive Schäden verursacht
in Stockholm hat die königlich
Schwedische Akademie der Wissenschaften
den Nobelpreis für Chemie vergeben er
geht dann die Amerikanerin Caroline Berg
Tussi ihren Landsmann Berry sharples
sowie den Dänen mortal
er und die beiden anderen Preisträger
hätten bahnbrechendes bei der
Entwicklung von Methoden zum
zielgerichteten Aufbau von Biomolekülen
geleistet mit ihrer Forschung hätten sie
die Grundlage für die sogenannte Klick
Chemie gelegt so die Begründung der
Akademie damit lassen sich molekulare
Bausteine vergleichsweise schnell und
einfach verbinden
Frauen Leben Freiheit das ist der
führende Slogan der Protestbewegung in
Iran geworden der Tod einer jungen Frau
war der Auslöser an der Unterdrückung
der Frauen wird die Menschenverachtung
dieses Regimes besonders sichtbar aber
auch die Wut des Volkes manifestiert
sich besonders in der Wut der Frauen die
sich den Schleier vom Kopf reißen und
sie tun das landauf Land ab in Schulen
eine Universitäten auf der Straße selbst
14 und 15-jährige Mädchen demonstrieren
das Ausland schaut zu staunend wundernd
mitfühlend aber auch hilflos viel mehr
als moralische Unterstützung gibt es
bislang nicht in Deutschland haben
mehrere hundert Kulturschaffen einen
unterstützerbrief an die Protestierenden
gerichtet in Frankreich treten
prominente Frauen vor die Kamera Kamera
für die Freiheit sagt Juliette binosch
und schneidet sich die Haare ab
genauso wie Marion cotilla Isabelle
Jenny und über 50 andere französische
Schauspielerinnen und Künstlerinnen
sie zeigen sich solidarisch mit der
Protestbewegung und den Frauen in Iran
die wir hier täglich erniedrigt oder
geschlagen werden
auch heute wieder erreichen uns Bilder
landesweiter Proteste wie hier an der
Universität Teheran oder der
medizinischen Universitäten rascht im
Norden
Solidarität auch von einer
EU-Parlamentarierin
weder die Geschichte noch Allah oder der
allmächtige Gott werden euch für eure
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
vergeben die er gegen euer eigenes Volk
begeht
wir die Staaten und Menschen der EU
fordern den sofortigen und
bedingungslosen Stopp der Gewalt gegen
Frauen und Männer in Iran
Frauen Leben Freiheit
das macht auch immer mehr Schülerinnen
in Iran Mut hier singen sie die Hymne
der Freiheit
anderswo rufen Sie nach Freiheit wie
hier bei Teheran
oder jagen ihren Direktor aus der Schule
hier reißen Sie Bilder des obersten
religiösen Führers herunter darauf steht
in Iran die Todesstrafe doch das Regime
schlägt brutal zurück die 17-jährige
Nika chakrami verschwindet am 20
September spurlos jetzt wurde ihr
Leichnam freigegeben er zeigt Spuren von
Gewalt
Nachrichten die auch die über eine
Million Menschen zählende iranische
Community im Großraum Los Angeles
erreichen
unsere Sorge ist dass wir in den letzten
Jahrzehnten immer wieder Unruhen hatten
und sie jedes Mal durch
Sicherheitskräfte niedergeschlagen
wurden dieses Mal aber ist es
beispiellos wir sehen Menschen die
zurückschlagen und eine direkte
Botschaft an das Regime senden wir
wollen keine Islamische Republik mehr
diese Botschaft kommt an in diesen Tagen
über die besondere Rolle der Frauen in
dieser Protestbewegung will ich mit
meiner Kollegin goline sprechen
eigentlich unsere Korrespondentin in
Kairo derzeit aber auf Heimatbesuch in
Deutschland Gulli nee du bist selbst in
Teheran geboren hast enge Bindung in das
Land und letztes Jahr hast du ein Buch
veröffentlicht mit dem Titel Iran die
Freiheit ist weiblich und wenn man sich
die Proteste jetzt ansieht dann ja da
war dieser Titel gerade zu prophetisch
ja tatsächlich hat im Laufe der
Geschichte der Islamischen Republik
keine gesellschaftliche Gruppe so sehr
um ganz elementare Grundrechte kämpfen
müssen wie die iranischen Frauen und
keine Gruppe hat der Islamischen
Republik so viel Schaden zugefügt wie
die iranischen Frauen durch
millionenfache Akte des zivilen
Ungehorsams sie kann in Psychoterror die
Angst vor der Sittenpolizei auf den
Straßen nicht mehr ertragen und genau
deswegen ist doch der Tod von massagina
Amini ein Fanal gewesen für die Frauen
Irans er hat eine unglaubliche
Bindungskraft entfaltet viele viele
Menschen können sich damit
identifizieren die schmerzhaften
Erfahrungen mit der Sittenpolizei das
ist etwas das Millionen iranische
Familien erlebt haben und dass sie so
nicht weiter dulden insofern die Frauen
haben mit ihren Protest mit ihrem
zivilen Ungehorsam eine moralische
Autorität erlangt die ihnen auch von den
Männern jetzt zugebilligt wird um eine
Regierungsrolle einzunehmen das ist ein
faszinierende Entwicklung aber es ist ja
nicht die erste Protestwelle in Iran es
ist gab ja auch immer wieder Hoffnung
auf Veränderungen oder wenigstens
Reformen etwas mehr Öffnung und am Ende
wurde das immer Niederungen und die
Hardliner behielten das Zepter in der
Hand wie schätzt du das ein kann es
diesmal anders sein also zu einer
richtigen Revolution sogar werden
ja einerseits haben wir das gesehen das
ist Proteste gab und daraufhin keine
Reformen andererseits sehen wir
besonders seit fünf Jahren durch die
Proteste sich für vielfältigen dass sie
sich beschleunigen das ist in immer
kürzeren Abständen Proteste gibt dass
diese Proteste jetzt in der
außergewöhnliche Intensität zeigen
außergewöhnliche Protestformen auch
zeigen indem Demonstranten Demonstranten
in die Sicherheitskräfte tatsächlich
zurückschlagen insofern können wir
natürlich sagen dass das Regime durch
Repression eine gesellschaftliche
Entwicklung verlangsamen kann bis es
sich Zeit kaufen kann dass wir aber
durchaus ganz ganz ernste Risse im
Prozess sehen im Land sehen im Regime
sehen und diese Fälle von immer neuen
Toten immer neuen erschossenen
demonstrantenen zum Beispiel auch der
gerade angesprochene Fall von Nica
sharani die alle Anzeichen von
Vergewaltigung zeigt die ein äußerst
qualvollen Tod gestorben ist mit einem
zertrümmerten Schädel aufgefunden wurde
all das sendet ja der Protestbewegung
neue Impulse insofern haben wir es mit
einem absoluten legitimitätsverlust des
Regimes zu tun und der kann eigentlich
nicht aufgehalten werden es wird
wahrscheinlich ein längeren
revolutionären Prozess geben im Iran
danke dir für die Einschätzung
und jetzt noch mal eins mit Wirtschaft
die ölallianz opec+ fährt ihre
Produktion zurück das wurde heute nach
einem Ministertreffen bekannt gegeben
damit gab der Verbund dem Druck der USA
und anderer Staaten nicht nach die gegen
Förderkürzungen waren Frank Bethmann wie
wird sich das auswirken das Ziel der
opec-plus ist ganz klar höhere Preise
man reagiere mit der Verknappung des
Angebots auf den kräftigen
Preisrückgangs der letzten Monate hieß
es heute zum ersten Mal seit der
Pandemie haben sich die Vertreter des
ölbündnisses wieder physisch in Wien und
nicht virtuell getroffen ab November
wird der Verbund aus 23 Staaten 2
Millionen Barrel Öl täglich weniger
fördern die stärkste Kürzung seit langem
in der Erwartung dieses Schrittes steigt
der Preis bereits seit einigen Tagen die
Nordsee Sorte Brent verteuert sich im
Verlauf gleich um knapp sieben Prozent
Kopfschütteln vielerorts die Welt steckt
in einer Energiekrise da passe es nicht
wenn die ölländer den Hahn zudrehen
würden schimpfen die Kritiker war es
allerdings auch dass die
opec-plus-staaten insgesamt bereits
jetzt weniger fördern als die
Vereinbarungen erlauben würden unter
anderem wegen der Sanktionen gegen
Russland und den Iran im Prinzip passt
man die Förderquoten also den Realitäten
an der Aufwärtstrend beim DAX dennoch
beendet das Kursbarometer verliert 1,2
Prozent oder 153 Punkte sorgen aber
machen sich nicht nur die Börsianer auch
für Autofahrer und Heizölkunden sind das
keine guten Nachrichten die Preise
dürften wieder anziehen Frank Bethmann
vielen Dank gerne
Bayerns ehemalige Landtagspräsidentin
Barbara Stamm ist gestorben im Alter von
77 Jahren stammstand von 2008 bis 2018
an der Spitze des Bayerischen Landtags
dem sie insgesamt 42 Jahre lang
angehörte sie war zudem 13 Jahre lang
Mitglied der Staatsregierung wenn es zur
Präsident Söder würdigte Stamm als
Bayerns soziales Gewissen Maßstab und
Vorbild im Einsatz für die Mitmenschen
zwei US-Astronauten und eine russische
Kosmonautin sowie ein Japaner sind
gemeinsam auf dem Weg zur
Internationalen Raumstation ISS vom
weltraumzentrum Cape Canaveral in
Florida startete ihr rund 30-stündiger
Flug sie sollen dann fünf Monate auf der
ISS bleiben und zahlreiche Experimente
durchführen
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball Champions
League vom Abend RB Leipzig hat
gegenseitig Glasgow gewonnen drei zu
eins und Bayer Leverkusen das gestern in
der Champions League 0:2 beim FC Porto
verloren hat trennt sich von Trainers
Johann nee das gab Bayern 04 am Abend
bekannt und auch den Nachfolger schabi
Alonso und alles zum dritten Spieltag
hier im ZDF Sportstudio UEFA Champions
League von 23 Uhr an und in der ZDF
heute App und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto
am Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 9 10 17 37 38 49 Superzahl 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotte.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
herausragende brillante Drehbuchautoren
sind eh eine errare Spezies der Filmwelt
noch seltener werden Sie selbst über die
Branche hinaus berühmt
Wolfgang Kohlhase war auch in der
Hinsicht ein Ausnahmekünstler eine der
ganz großen im deutschen Film als
Drehbuchautor und Regisseur in der DDR
und später im wiedervereinigten
Deutschland ein Menschen Beobachter ein
Sozialkritiker und immer wieder auch ein
Chronist Berlins der Stadt in der
erlebte und jetzt im Alter von 91 Jahren
starb Christa Läpple erinnert an ihn und
sein Werk
Achtung Sunny Aufnahme es folgt dein
solo
Originaltext Wolfgang Kohlhase
ich schlafe mit jemanden wenn es mir
Spaß macht ich nenne Ecken pinkeln
kleinen Ecken pink gleich bin die die
bei den Tornados rausgeflogen ist ich
heiße Sunny
war es ein gesamtdeutscher Durchbruch
gemeinsam mit Renate grössner als Sunny
und Regisseur Konrad Wolf
[Musik]
kohlhaases preisgekrönte Liebeserklärung
an seine Heimatstadt Ostberlin sein
Motto man muss permanent suchen man muss
immer gucken man darf nicht nur Leute
befragen unter dem Gesichtspunkt kann
ich das gebrauchen das was man nicht
gebrauchen kann ist scheinbar nicht ist
oft das Beste
schreiben ist sein Leben der Vater ein
Maschinenschlosser fördert sein Talent
bereits mit 16 verfasste der erste
Kurzgeschichten seine Bühne wird berlin
die Stadt die sich teilt seine Texte
sind lakonisch und voller Mutterwitz
1957 entsteht Berlin Ecke Schönhauser
über Berliner Jungs im
Generationenkonflikt
1968 das anti-kriegsdrama ich war 19
Regie auch hier Konrad Wolf
den Film Berlin um die Ecke jedoch
verschwindet in den Archiven zu kritisch
für die Genossen ich bin mit den Filmen
von von Wolfgang groß geworden
sozialisiert ich komme ja aus dem
ehemaligen Osten da waren seine Filme
Kult wer war für mich ein Film Gott ja
nach dem Untergang der DDR macht der
Berliner weiter die Filme die am machen
will ihm gelingt etwas Besonderes aus
dem Stillen DDR Drehbuchschreiber wird
einer der großen im vereinten
Deutschland über drei Dutzend Drehbücher
verfasste er für Regisseure wie Volker
Schlöndorff oder Andreas Dresen darunter
der publikums-erfolg sommerform Balkon
eine Komödie über zwei Berlinerinnen mit
dem vertrauten kohlhasemix aus Präzision
Witz und Schlagfertigkeit mein Gesicht
doch noch so glatt wäre wie mein Arsch
hast du den Arsch aber lange nicht
gesehen Elena er hatte einen sehr
liebevollen Blick auf Menschen und zwar
sowohl auf die Menschen mit denen er zu
tun hatte seine Lebens- und
Arbeitspartner und seine Freunde aber
auch auf die Figuren von denen erzählt
hat
als wir träumten war einer seiner
letzten großen Filme nun hat er stets
jung gebliebene Erzähler Kohlhase die
Bühne mit 91 verlassen zum Glück bleiben
seine Geschichten
so viel von uns gleich folgt das
auslandsjournal unter anderem mit einer
Reportage von Katrin Eigendorf aus der
Ukraine sie berichtet aus zwei Städten
die jetzt von den Ukrainern befreit
wurden und um 0.40 gibt es dann unsere
heutigen Update mit Nazan gökdemir
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
abend weiterhin ist diese lang gezogene
Hochdruckzone für unser Wetter bestimmt
und bringt uns zum einen viel Sonne zum
anderen morgens auch Nebel die Kaltfront
die uns jetzt heute Nacht und morgen
einmal überquert die ist kaum
wetterwirksam sie bringt in der ersten
Nachthälfte im Nordwesten immer mal
wieder einen Schauer dann kommt sie in
die Mitte voran und der Regen wird so
langsam weniger sternenkla bleibt es im
Südosten hier bildet sich dann auch vor
allem Nebel und es bleibt am kühlsten
mit sechs bis neun Grad morgen früh
ansonsten ist es morgen früh bei
Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 14 Grad
nicht besonders kühl morgen liegen die
Wolken dieser Kaltfront vor allem
zwischen meinen und Donau oder Nebel im
Südosten löst sich schnell aus auf aus
diesen Wolken fällt aber kaum mal ein
Tropfen Regen und dasselbe gilt für die
Wolken hier an den Küsten bei einem
kräftigen westlichen Wind viel Sonne
gibt es morgen im Westen des Landes und
im norddeutschen Tiefland dazu ist es
etwas Schüler als heute 16 17 Grad gibt
es in den Mittelgebirgen und an den
Küsten am Bodensee da erreichen wir aber
noch einmal zweiundzwanzig grad am
Freitag haben wir ähnlich ruhiges Wetter
bei einer ähnlichen Temperaturspanne am
Samstag ist es dann im Nordwesten und
auch im Süden etwas wechselhafter schon
am Sonntag bleibt es aber wieder ruhiger
und die Temperaturen gehen etwas zurück
der temperaturtrend von Berlin der zeigt
uns hier dass das aber kein großer
temperatureinbruch wird also so langsam
gehen die Temperaturen etwas zurück das
war es von uns tschüss